[Music]
aurora cannon is three and battling
covet inside an oklahoma hospital
her mother is a nurse who says she
likely passed the virus to her daughter
from an unvaccinated patient the mother
posted these videos on social media to
show the world the price her young child
is paying writing if you choose not to
be vaccinated you've made a choice for
my daughter too your choice led to my
innocent child being hospitalized
pediatric intensive care units across
the southern u.s are filling with
children diagnosed with covid who are
too young to be vaccinated themselves
these patients sometimes can't breathe
and we have to help them we have to help
breathe for them
since the delta variant took hold it's
been busy here at children's hospital
new orleans in louisiana a state where
vaccinations are among the country's
lowest oftentimes we get to work and
before we can even put our bags down we
hit the ground running for the day and
we're in and out of rooms all day
resuscitating kids
you know giving them oxygen increasing
their support
u.s child covid cases declined in early
summer but has steadily increased since
july last week more than 120 thousand
cases were reported in children across
the country a substantial jump from the
week before we are absolutely convinced
that the more people that get vaccinated
the fewer people that will be infected
that's clearly demonstrated and the
fewer children that will be infected
deaths remain rare among children with
kovid but doctors fear more children
will die as more are hospitalized
after 11 days in the hospital aurora is
finally well enough to go home
soon she and other young children may
qualify for vaccinations ochsner health
in new orleans is studying the pfizer
shots in children under 12. the trial's
medical director says the data looks
promising and there have been no safety
problems in participants we have some of
the children between the five to 11
which are sort of very grown up and they
themselves want to participate we had a
little one and he goes pull up his shirt
he said sign me up
five year old
an application for fda emergency
authorization for that age group is
expected from pfizer in about a month
it couldn't come soon enough for the
parents of some children the challenge
will be convincing those who've refused
vaccines even for themselves
heidi joe castro al jazeera new orleans
louisiana